Yeah.
This episode comes with a very strong content warning for frank discussions of
and immediate clips involving rape and sexual harassment.
Okay.
There's a surprisingly disturbing trend running through a lot of mass media
entertainment,
a trend that often flies under the radar.
Let me explain.
You're watching a popular TV show or movie laughing along at the high jinks when
suddenly things take a jarring term,
chuck go,
I'm going to smother you and Julie.
Wait a minute.
That
a rape joke.
I'm going to smother you up and giving up and Julie Go.
Yup.
Certainly was this one.
Here is our booty.
Maybe it's just an anomaly.
That's an end with us riding into the sunset.
It ends with me dying of cancer and you winning the icebox award for softest
mouse.
Hold up.
That's another rape joke in another superhero.
Blockbuster.
Let's try something else.
Don't drop the soap.
Big homie.
Where will you be watching the working consume me from.
That's right.
A prison.
So I'll send you Barstow.
How about we try a comedy instead?
Lacks and open.
Why wait,
wait
my ass.
Yikes.
Let's switch to a TV show.
As soon as you dropped the soap,
Dave rape your buck.
That's what happens.
I'm saying
uh,
Bieber was at briefly jailed early this morning.
He went to jail early this morning and the police report described him as five
foot nine and 140 pounds or as is suddenly put it just right.
Okay.
Likely notice the pattern here.
In each case,
sexual assault is played for laughs and in each case,
the targets of the joke are men.
He's like a bite size seekers.
Yeah.
Hi.
Scenarios involving the sexual abuse of men can include a wide range of
behavior.
No,
we'll do when you're in scene.
Prom casual punch lines about unwanted kissing or touching
gratuitous one liners about anal rape.
They will charge your butthole and told parking garage.
Start putting O'Connor causing their man Buicks.
Carla Sierra's Oldsmobiles.
Somebody's going to put her in Amia.
Yeah,
no,
don't buy down.
It's hard to overstate just how common jokes about men being sexually assaulted
are most popular comedic actors and their writers engage in this type of humor.
She'll look at me,
I'll get raped like crazy too.
Yeah,
totally.
I get raped just as much as you would think you're more capable than I hate
nick.
I'm not saying anything like that.
Okay.
You're pretty close to say
statistically speaking,
men are far more likely to be the perpetrators of sexual violence then our
people of any other gender.
And so that's what we'll be focusing on in this video.
We'll examine media in which women are portrayed as perpetrators in a future
episode.
He's,
he's the one who famously said,
I'd take a bullet for Donald Trump.
Well,
nowadays looking at prison time,
we'll see if he's willing to take a dick.
Sexual assault of man has comedy is so ubiquitous and so normalized that you may
not have even noticed.
It shows up everywhere.
And when I say everywhere,
I mean everywhere,
even at the Oscars.
And why does all per his nerve to rob for this soap because no one wants to do
it alone.
Speaking of songs
is about male rape.
There seem to be an awful lot of them
hands against the prison while show Kane on a mouthful.
The ball.
Yeah.
His sex slave.
You couldn't go go.
Me and Nathan.
Oh,
whoa.
The sexual assault of men is a Goto joke for many popular animated sitcoms.
Rick and Morty go to giant prison.
You know,
if somebody drops the soap,
it's going to land in our heads and crush our spines.
Morty,
you know,
it'll be really easy to rape us after that.
Yeah.
What do you collect?
Mass Lane.
Okay,
let's do it.
Not like this
because well,
you slept a violet.
Did you?
Repeatedly.
You might be surprised to find out that slightly less explicit variations on
these jokes also show up in children's media with alarming regularity.
This is never going to work.
Of course,
it will look very pretty.
That's what they'll say in jail.
Love is in the air,
judge.
It just smell it.
Did you see what's up there?
Just that guys cherry.
You got any idea what they do to exit San Ricardo prison?
It ain't over easy.
Notice how these jokes are all designed to demean,
humiliate or emasculate a male character for being the victim or potential
victim of sexual violence.
The me too movement has brought to light the rampant sexual abuse perpetrated by
powerful men in Hollywood.
Well,
many of those telling their stories have been famous women.
There were also a handful of male celebrities coming forward as survivors,
including actors,
Rapp and Terry Cruz.
Cruz has been especially vocal even testifying about his experience in front of
Congress in support of the survivor's bill of rights,
where he stressed that sexual assault isn't really about sex,
it's about power.
I was sexually assaulted by a successful Hollywood Asian.
The assault lasted only minutes,
but what he was effectively telling me while he held my genitals and his hand
was that he held the power that he was in control.
Since coming forward,
Terry Cruz has faced a good deal of backlash from other straight men and it's no
coincidence that much of the ridicule directed at him.
Bayer's an uncanny resemblance to the punchlines we're discussing in this video.
This is how toxic masculinity permeates culture.
As I shared my story,
I was told over and over that this was not abuse,
that this was just a joke.
As with all comedy,
it's important to ask who or what is being targeted by the joke.
So let's take a few examples from popular mainstream comedies and talk about
what we're meant to be laughing at and why.
Because it's the why that helps eliminate how underlying messages can have a
negative impact on the way we think about assault and masculinity.
Fetologist standing by best one you can find
in the 2015 comedy,
get hard will Farrell plays a wealthy hedge fund manager who finds out he's
going to prison for embezzlement.
The core premise of the movie is that Farrow's character is terrified of being
raped in prison.
There's a hundred percent chance that you're going to be somebody's bitch.
Kevin Hart's character exploits that panic to get hired as a toughness coach to
help prepare him for life on the inside.
This setup,
as you might imagine,
leads to a steady stream of rape jokes.
You know what that is?
That's a big ass black men.
When you're Pale White,
I don't want any more.
That's enough.
Too late.
He didn't tag the next guy in.
At the heart of these jokes is the perceived emasculation of men who are scared
of or become emotional over the possibility of sexual assault.
Hey,
listen up everyone.
I'm extremely sad
thought we have already to set.
Hey fellows,
my heart's already been right.
Get hard is just one of many,
many examples where male characters on the receiving end of sexual assault jokes
are framed as weak,
cowardly,
a feminine or unmanly obviously.
Yup.
Kenny.
Kenny,
stop crying.
Stop crying.
Can he look at me?
Yes.
Show me a mean face.
Kenny
men's vulnerability is an endless source of mockery in mainstream comedy and
vulnerability that results from sexual violence is no exception.
I don't want to go to jail.
I know.
You know what happens?
A handsome guy like me in jail and Ron's a drape.
We were also great.
Just keep your mouth shut and try not to cry
to cry.
Crying ticks to set up the idea behind the joke.
Here.
He is as obvious as it is toxic that men who aren't tough or manly enough to
avoid being victimized are pathetic and therefore deserving of ridicule or
worse.
Hey guys,
did you think he's anyone's girlfriend yet?
He's been in jail for three hours.
Of course he's had one we'd go out for then punch lines about men being sexually
assaulted usually revolve around the idea of a man being made subordinate to
another man and therefore forced into a role that is stereotypically feminine.
I am
never going on a Beta.
Same emasculation jokes are supposed to be funny because in a patriarchal
culture like ours,
we're meant to think that there is no greater humiliation for a man then to be
treated like a woman.
We'll talk extensively about the 2005 hit comedy wedding crashers in part two of
this video series,
but the movie deserves a mention here as well because of how it frames one of
several sexual assaults committed against Vince Fonz characters.
The basic setup is that Vaughn,
as our lovable chauvinist suddenly has the tables turned on
comfortable.
I'm not going to want that.
What's the reason?
It's your typical gross out comedies scenario design could make audiences laugh,
squeamish Lee at seeing straight male characters thrust into awkward sexual
situations with other men.
There's an underlying homophobia running through scenes like this,
which is connected to some extreme levels of anxiety around straight male
sexuality.
Oh pop out at the right moment.
The insinuation is that if a man is sexually harassed by another man,
Jesus Christ,
it means he's perceived.
Yeah.
As gay
and being perceived as gay is supposed to be deeply humiliating for straight men
and open your mouth guards to go about getting your Dick sucked up.
You're the ones who escaped for sucking Majid.
I will report to you.
You will go to jail or you won't have to pretend to be gay because your assets
will be busier than a test bench and a plunger factory.
Despite what media may tell us.
It's critical to remember that being sexually assaulted has absolutely nothing
to do with someone's sexuality
just as it has nothing to do with their masculinity.
If the perpetrator is coded as a gay man or a character of ambiguous sexual
identity,
then sexual assault is usually framed as a product of some uncontrollable sexual
desire,
which then works to demonize gay men buying directly,
linking them to predatory behavior.
I have a question.
Are you single?
Uh,
I'm not gay.
I don't care.
You're a hunky and I'm what they call predatory gay.
It's made worse if as is often the case,
the rapist is the only gay coded character in the whole production.
All of this contributes to the long running pattern in Hollywood where gay
sexuality is framed as a clear and present danger to straight people,
which it isn't.
Queer sexuality is not a threat to straight people.
Rapists are a threat to straight people just as they are a threat to people of
all genders and all sexualities.
In 2016 the Metta Ironic Superhero movie,
Deadpool,
starring Ryan Reynolds became the highest grossing r rated film in history and
one of its opening scenes provides us with a good example of another common
media pattern,
the scared straight style rape joke
and our general direction again,
and you will learn in the worst of ways that I have some hard spots too
that came out wrong.
The punchline here revolves around a male superhero weaponizing the performance
of an ambiguous queer sexuality as a form of intimidation.
The joke comes from the same place as the overprotective father.
Freak out.
Whatever you do to my daughter,
I do to you.
You want,
it
seems like this end up accidentally illustrating an important point because it's
not just the act of sexual assault itself that functions as an instrument of
domination and control in our culture.
Get in.
It's also the threat of sexual assault.
You know what turned out means nothing?
No Sir.
It's when a straight dude rolls into prison and gets his ass fucked.
Then becomes a girl.
Big Boys would come in and push a little more like you down.
Maybe stick a textbook in your mouth and go to fucking town.
What that happened to you?
I don't think so.
Sexual assault is in many ways simply another form of violence and leveraging
the threat of that violence as a deterrent to keep young men and boys in line is
a frequent theme in media.
Well,
you better keep though.
Damn mouth shut.
Oh No.
You're going to be going back to the showers and the only speed you're going to
reach is 88 dudes.
Bow.
Probably noticed by now that a lot of this comedy has something in common he did
involves prison rape.
Wow.
Prison rape jokes are so pervasive in mass media entertainment at the phrase,
don't drop the soap has become a routine sight gag.
Despite the insinuation of anal rape,
don't drop the soap.
Punchlines have also found their way into children's cartoons.
Where do advice don't drop the soap got balloons now,
God,
I'm one of the reasons these rape jokes pass under the radar is because for
straight adult men of able body and mind,
the possibility of being sexually assaulted isn't a real concern in their
everyday lives.
The one exception to that,
and it's a big one.
Our street adult men who are incarcerated,
prison rape is a rampant,
horrifying problem that destroys lives.
Okay?
Each year,
over 200,000 people are raped or sexually assaulted while in prison in the
United States.
It is important to remember that just like on the outside,
sexual assault in prison should not be confused with consensual sex between
prisoners.
Do you know what they do to soft,
bald,
overweight Republican's in prison?
Earnest.
While the vast majority of the comedy we've been looking at invokes the rape of
straight men.
In reality,
it's queer and transgender prisoners who are most likely to be the targets of
sexual assault in prison.
Many prison rape jokes also carry with them some explicit racist overtones.
It's no accident that punchlines regularly involved white men being threatened
with rape by a big scary black man.
So I've got new volunteer,
Huh?
Well,
let me tell you cupcakes.
What's your first day?
It don't expect no flowers afterwards.
Scenes like this one are built around the racist idea that black men are more
brutal,
aggressive or predatory than other men,
and that therefore it's black men specifically who pose a special threat to
white men's masculinity.
So it was a beautiful white boy like you doing in place like this.
Terry crews,
his story about being sexually assaulted is so powerful because it that scary,
intimidating black man narrative.
Before his personal evolution,
some of those scary characters were even played by cruise himself to see him now
choosing to speak up and be publicly vulnerable challenges those racist media
myths about black masculinity.
When my assault happened,
quite honestly,
uh,
I probably would have been laughed out of the police station.
It's not unusual for police officers or other authority figures to be shown
engaging in forms of dark comedy that involve the sexual violation of men
procedural style dramas in particular,
frequently to pick law enforcement officials,
threatening male suspects with rape as a way to get them to talk.
Do you have any idea what it's like in sing sing for a guy with your
limitations?
You're going to be the poster boy for bitch of the month.
When are you not getting the dice?
Nope.
It's how it goes.
She's selling rolls the dice.
Nah,
it's made days.
You get to play his girlfriend.
Prison guard isn't an inmate.
I hear.
They make you prom queen and every night is prom night.
You talk now and we'll make sure you're not putting him with the general
population.
When I get it
to see the look of love and a meat wranglers,
I had a damn make some spoiled rich kid is no celly.
Look on the bright side.
In prison,
you want to have to pay for dates.
Writers seem to love these extra judicial taunts and use them as a source of
Shodan.
Freud out
shot him.
Freud,
it's German.
But when you feel good because your enemies anus has been violated,
the quips are designed to elicit a satisfied snicker from viewers at seeing the
bad guys
square.
It's up.
Could be started at felony or you could be shared.
So this filler rod here,
you'd like that.
Would you see there?
You're already making friends.
For some reason,
Denzel Washington has a lot of dialogue to this effect in his filmography.
This time next week I'll be sucking down Pina coladas and a hot tub with six
girls named amber and Tiffany,
more likely
taking a shower with two guys named Jamal and Hey Susan,
if you know what I mean?
And here's the bad news.
The thing is sucking on,
it's not a Pina Colada.
You better have some divine intervention,
buddy.
You better have some k y you're going to need
you a term of no less than four years in a federal prison.
So why does this matter?
Well,
the harsh reality is that rape is one of the unofficial but widely sanctioned
ways that criminal justice institutions punish undesirable prisoners,
especially Queer men,
trans folks,
and people with mental disabilities.
You know,
do you know what this means?
Don't you
make no mistake?
The powers that be allow prison rape to happen sometimes too passive
facilitation and other times through direct participation.
It's part of how the prison system maintains control over men's bodies and
sexualities while they're incarcerated.
There's just one of the thing I've got to check.
The type of police brutality as comedy that we've been talking about here isn't
designed to critique or aluminate the widespread of uses of law enforcement.
Even when police officers are shown as humorously and competent,
the jokes are still made at the expense of those being victimized
by and large audiences except these sadistic punchlines because of who the rape
threats are directed at.
You know what happens?
Pretty boys like you go up to the farm,
low stage charges.
We look at that.
I've got some 11 as long as it's criminal suspects being victimized and likable,
authority figures doing the victimizing,
then it's widely seen as criminals getting what they deserve.
You want to know about anarchy.
You don't tell me what another bone is going to make sure he's been your prison
time when you're big and it has a nice big smile on some context here,
what he say and tell the whole story.
I'll try new ways to be an entrance.
I don't know.
Brothers inside of till your guts up,
fucking you stupid.
When it's a cop drama.
The lead characters are generally presented,
has tough guys for occasionally tough gals who are being tough on crime.
He comes for you middle of the night when you're least expecting it,
you do me a favor.
This is often referred to as reciprocal punishment or Karmic justice.
Nice petite white boy like you,
the federal penitentiary.
I,
let me just put it this way.
I don't think you'll be able to remain anal retentive for very long.
It's a morally a parent,
but widely accepted idea.
Best encapsulated by the idiom.
An eye for an eye,
a tooth for tooth.
Don't you feel kind of bad for them?
Sure.
I feel lousy for her.
He's a murderer and he should pay for it with this life.
No.
He should be doing 60 years in a prison,
breaking rocks and making special friends with Roscoe,
the weightlifter.
Yikes.
The quality of mercy is not Buffy.
Sometimes these karmic rape plot lines involved villains being sexually
assaulted
with a weapon
or alternatively raped by a large male animal.
The word for this is injustice.
The word for it,
his revenge.
You know where you're going.
This crew,
people in a very uncomfortable place.
Now,
it should go without saying that rape can never ever be a form of justice.
When media frames the sexual assault of men,
even bad men as getting what they deserve,
it perpetuates a culture of rape.
Acceptance.
Pinos not some penis
means you could go to jail.
Where are you could get some pain.
Yes.
It also makes prison rape seem inevitable,
which it's not.
There are solutions to the prison rape epidemic,
namely keep people out of prison,
which means working towards mass d incarceration through a combination of
decriminalization and a focus on education and rehabilitation programs instead
of locking people up.
But with every casual prison rape joke,
it makes those goals more difficult to achieve.
I'm trying to talk about sexual assault.
It's not like that's a new topic in comedy without a rape drugs forever,
but it's just like those jokes have usually been like,
that's the full joke in an audience,
because that's a taboo word will have a response.
None that comic.
We'll hear that response.
Ooh,
I have done a good joke
as comedians like Cameron Esposito and Lindy West have pointed out,
it is possible to tell jokes about rape from a survivor's perspective where the
punchlines target rave culture.
But that's not what's happening in the movies and TV shows we've been looking at
here.
Oh,
oh no,
no,
no.
I'm,
I'm actually getting married
as we've seen again and again.
The targets of these jokes are the victims of sexual assault and harassment.
You're ready cause they're here.
What cubs.
Oh.
Which is why when actors,
writers or directors try to defend this type of comedy from criticism,
there are arguments.
Don't hold any water.
Anytime you're doing any comedy,
somebody is going to do somebody who's going to go,
go do,
do the face.
Oh my word.
But that's kind of what we do.
We provoke,
we prod,
we,
we also show a mirror up to what's already existing out there.
You know,
the idea that these comedians are somehow bravely pushing boundaries or
fearlessly transgressing taboos by telling prison rape jokes.
He is pure self delusion.
So now he comes,
God wants to rub your face.
Ha,
I liked his hair.
He's breathing on you.
That's disgusting.
But guess what?
You can look forward to 10 years of it.
When Will Ferrell or Kevin Hart or Adam Sandler or any other famous comedian
amplifies dismissive and toxic ideas about rape in their comedy routines.
It's not meant to raise awareness and it's certainly not designed to hold up a
mirror and give voice to rape survivors.
Let me guess.
You drop the soap,
please take that out of my ass.
They're acting out these rape jokes because it's an easy way to get cheap
laughs,
Charlie.
And the price of those laughs is the further trivialization of rape in a culture
that already doesn't take survivors serious things.
Okay,
so you were violated by two people while you are under the gas.
So what?
Yes,
single.
Well,
at the same time as we've talked about reinforcing a whole bunch of aggressive
ways of thinking around race,
masculinity,
sexuality,
and criminal justice.
Beyond that,
these jokes also give people permission to continue silencing and shaming
survivors.
Brian,
if you don't mind,
we'll start thinking up by prison rape jokes immediately.
If Hollywood writers and Comedians really want to break taboos and push
boundaries,
they could try treating survivors of sexual assault with a measure of dignity
and empathy because that would be a guaranteed way to shock their audience.
Thanks for watching.
Now I know this can be a difficult and intense topic,
so I've left a bunch of resources and additional information in the text below
this video.
I want to thank all of my scripted visors for their invaluable feedback in
writing this episode,
especially Reverend Jason Liden,
who founded an organization called black and pink,
which is dedicated to supporting queer prisoners.
You can find that link in the description below as well.
In part two of this discussion,
we'll shift focus and talk about media where women assaulting men is played for
laughs.
If you'd like to support my video series,
you can do that over on Patrion and I've left a link to paypal in the
description below.
See you next time.